there are reports that have fallen back
at the Cosmodrome keeping a pretty tight
guard on the old Skywatch could be one
of their readers or it could be
something valuable the speaker's asking
guardians to look into it t even this
ship Star Wars that's so Star Wars he
saw Star Wars
okay the sky watchers just on the other
side and then this is super hailer
surrounded by mm-hmm well I'm ready if
you are I'm so ready I'm so ready that
sky watch
Oh mmm thank you where'd you go nobody
I'm afraid that's right that's like I
wonder if I have it upgrade oh wait it's
an MMO I can't just pulls whenever I
want I'm pretty sure I just have to go
this way still like can't see anyone at
least earlier when I was playing to get
to this point so like a few people
around and we danced like like this like
yep once once once oh yeah all right
stop that's enough dancing isn't some
kind of dance simulator what are you
doing I actually do think like the dance
is like quite well designed though like
it's gone more than like one move you
know you like does a little knee thing
occasionally aren't enough dancing man
not dancing we've got really important
stuff to do like save the world from the
darkness the children are really
frightened and all you want to do is
dance I don't even think I go to name my
character actually I'm pretty sure it's
Charl amazon I usually named anything in
an MMO k Owain to match my white hat
it's like I have the same character in
every single MMO it's ridiculous who
even does that this guy this guy does
because I am an unoriginal tool all
right you call it a hill I would call
that the wing of a plane but I wratten's
go with Hill let's go with him sup you
reckon you reckon I'll get that I don't
think I'll get that nope I knew davage
hey like hey oh oh oh I did not think
this through mmm
sup sucka take so long to reload at
least I can whenever I want pretty much
that's handy we don't even need to go
this way but you know what I will I'm
gonna do it hello a level 5 vandal you
don't seem suited to level 5 neither he
do actually well we cast level 5 he's
got his little flame gun in a more bulk
what a cool guy I regret shooting him go
home I had a mohawk once you guys I'm
not even kidding i'd like a it was
really cool but if I explain it it just
sounds like a bargain mullet um but I
had like a long and like a lung fringe
and then just like really short like in
that top middle bit and if i spiked it
it'll be like a mohawk but with like hey
on either side and I mean I thought it
was cool and that like was this like
checking very 12 who at the time I
thought was really really cool who said
she raided my hair she was like not a 10
but I raid it I was like she's a real
estate agent now
Angie I think I name was she commented
that back on my myspace it's like yeah
thanks Ange I didn't say that I don't
think I said anything I think I was like
was like some some weird fan go just cuz
she was like old ax and pretty
yeah this is really hot this is really
hard to do for me to play this and
trying to say it entertaining things so
I'm just telling you about some gonna
comment on my mohawk and dying that's
what I'm doing I need to pay more
attention to what i'm doing here come on
respawn yeah okay um so yeah the whole
face cam thing doesn't work too well
when you guys need to be honest so maybe
i'll do it for this and like a couple
more destiny videos and then i'd prefer
to go back to just microphone een so i
can just like sit on my couch like an
idiot really far away from the TV i'm
really close to the TV right now so that
I can actually have the webcam in like a
way that walks and I can play the game
better but you know people will ask for
it so ya gotta give the people what they
want what's that from accorded something
your scent I totally just quoted
something I think I was quoting
Everybody Loves Raymond yep oh that
looks big captain hey seen a few year
before how many captains are there you
guys look really uncoordinated you see
that many goddamn captain's getting [ __ ]
together oh I should have mentioned a
disclaimer at the sound of this video
that any kind of let squad who tends to
have swearing so sorry if anyone
splendid I am just proud of my vocab
baby I'm not ashamed of it to be honest
another people who really don't like
swearing but I swear um I'm really proud
of myself in that mean the entire time
we've been working on radio which is
every single week for three years now
I've never sworn and I talk a lot when
I'm on the radio who'd have thought
right but I really do and never never
swan
who's being Russia why is all the
writing in english in soviet russia i
can get it open okay
open it love a bit Shh
he's doing it let's get it done ok
let's do this this is where the flood
come on yes yes I know I know don't we
offer comfort everywhere it's crazy
stuff the hive it's even even the names
close to the flood Laurie this is crazy
i need help i really need someone else
with me here it's such a good strategy
though I've been doing this in a lot of
games lately where as soon as my health
goes down you just retreat to a point
where they end up backing off need to
turn the mic going down alright so it's
an effective strategy in majority of
video games and I think I mean we've
already been out of how I make all my
characters look like Geralt The Witcher
3 right so before I started reviewing
games and had to do like to a week I
used to play every single game on the
hardest difficulty just because I
enjoyed the challenge and the only game
that that I ever ever ever ever had to
turn on the difficulty of because it was
too hard was the witcher 3 and then I
realized like halfway through offertory
time difficulty down that it had that
same full way if you just back it up the
enemies just turn around I'm like the
guy you're over there it's such an
exploit I shouldn't do it you shouldn't
do it it's like ruining the game but
it's a nice little trick in it and it
sure helps with um with tricky stuff
like this where I should really have a
party with me but done all right well
let's kill the wizard then brah I'm also
part wizard
you ain't got [ __ ] damn oh I'm stuck I'm
stuck I'm stuck no no no I came didn't
really follow your nose for this come on
buddy
shooting at the ground and
everything's nice and lighten either I'm
actually like a total scaredy-cat when
it comes to games i got like terrified
like super super terrified um so you
know being in the dark back there wasn't
feeling too great about it but um I've
gotta say at this point everything in
this game all of the environments feel
quite see me but
that is because and I'm just I'm just
saying this as a disclaimer for anyone
who's watching it and you know not sure
if you want to play it um that's only
because i'm at the same planet
technically I'm on I'm on earth and I'm
in old Russia oh it's Russia where
agoura shoots you um so yeah there are
other places and they all look pretty
different I don't know I think it's good
it's got quite a nice variety same man
as any other MMO I guess nothing
particularly outstanding but it doesn't
all look totally the same like this but
it's just like kind of looks like
post-apocalyptic earth except not as
Google's fallout 3 because nothing is as
cool as fallout 3 some things maybe but
i really like fallout 3 you guys I'm
gonna yeah I don't know if you all
watched it but I've done let's play a
fable anniversary where I think I
mentioned in that I'm planning on just
occasionally doing what space of my
favorite parts of some of my favorite
games and tranquility lane from awful
lot 3 is definitely to be one of those
it's also what I largely is backing
music for a whole lot of my it was the
tranquility lane theme which is also a
my ringtone because i really like it
some people found that part of that game
scary i guess it was creepy depending on
which way you tried to play it but why
are we talking about that playing
destiny right now get you together Alana
he's a more infinitely spawning enemies
or as I like to call the free XP
damn a show comes back fast I need help
I see me difficult doing it by myself oh
do my best all rights back down what
banking fees I am confuse fosse stuffs
what is happening I like wasn't hitting
him but I'm like but maybe if i keep
shooting it'll eventually later why did
I keep trying and even know not even
there come on buddy I'm saying okay it
actually goes down for you foster
we need to get that thing down and stuff
from coming back up hey hi it's maybe he
like we're charges it do that maybe does
not screw you screw you Jeff yeah hide
hide I guess I'm doing the exact same
thing how can I complain i'm doing the
exact same thing he is where I'm just
like a recharge eagles on I can not
complain so much level for you probably
should get moving he makes a good point
let's get moving and nine seconds four
three two one mmm
miss this
I'm just dancing by myself right now